president Trump is coming to the defense
of Bill O'Reilly even as the list of
companies pulling ads from his fox news
show is growing nearly 50 companies have
dropped the o'reilly factor they are
responding to a report that O'Reilly and
Fox paid millions to settle multiple
harassment allegations Vladimir do ta of
our streaming network CBS n is here with
a fox stars high-profile vote of
confidence Vlad good morning good
morning the fox news host only comments
came over the weekend where he said as a
prominent person he was vulnerable to
lawsuits but he's made no mention of the
report on his national broadcast and
some speculate that he in the networker
hoping the controversy will die down and
no new revelations take its place thank
you thank you on the same day that
President Trump offered his support to
Jordan's King Abdullah he did the same
for Fox News host Bill O'Reilly in an
interview with The New York Times on
Wednesday he called O'Reilly a good
person saying I don't think bill did
anything wrong it's clear that Bill
O'Reilly and Donald Trump have a
relationship that goes back a ways so in
that sense it's almost not surprising
that the president would make the
comments of support that he did however
it came with quite a controversy hi I'm
Bill O'Reilly the New York Times
reported over the weekend that O'Reilly
and fox news reached settlements
totaling some 13 million dollars with
five women who accused the host with
sexual harassment or other inappropriate
behavior when asked by the paper about
O'Reilly Trump said personally I think
he shouldn't have settled because you
should have taken it all the way one
woman who told the times she did settle
responded on Twitter saying Fox's
employment agreements required mediation
and prevent going to court she also said
the president's comments made her feel
vilified all over again the fact I
begins right now meanwhile more
advertisers are taking their commercial
dollars elsewhere nearly 50 sponsors
including Subaru Eli Lilly and early
hold out Jenny Craig have now pulled
their O'Reilly Factor ads I think if
you're one of the many marketers who has
pulled out an ad from The O'Reilly
Factor you are weighing whether this is
just going to be a temporary thing or
perhaps something more permanent the
commercial minutes on The O'Reilly
Factor were down from Tuesday to
Wednesday from 18 to fewer than 13
it's but the show's ratings have
actually increased despite the
controversy or perhaps because of it
since quite a message out there it does
indeed Thank You Vlad